salut aujourd'hui je suis avec anthony
de la chaîne brut de capteurs de
capteurs une chaîne dédiée ou débutants
on va dire en photographie n'était
acquis avant les débutants il ya moi en
fait on
non sinon tu m'as parlé d'ouverture et
tous ses amis c'est vrai moi j'arrive
vers jean des mauvrets chic et rock de
retenir tous les autres c est passer
pour un expert de l'automobile ion 5
secondes et j'ai bien aimé ce que tu
faisais je trouvais ça cool et puis on a
eu un bon feeling on à échanger et
qu'est ce qui va se passer mais il va se
faire mentaliser tu vas te faire
mentaliser mais par mois et par eux
aussi vous êtes prêts à essayer je vais
t'emmener dans un univers particulier à
l'univers que je crois que tu ne connais
pas d'accord mais qui est pourtant un
lien avec la photo tu vas travailler
pour voilà c'est un nouveau magazine
c'est un mélange de joie aussi égal
comme tu veux aller faire une
paparazzade
quoique nous on n'est pas par hasard je
crois que c'est quand les people
organisent eux mêmes règles de bâle
alors non tu vas faire le pas paradis
très bien simplement le paparazzi que
vale photographier une star ok quelqu'un
qu'on connaît
j'ai qu'une contrainte c'est que ce soit
quelqu'un de français par contre ça peut
être de n'importe quel univers me dit
pas encore lequel on doit avoir des noms
qui vont commencer à devenir s'est déjà
fait bouger
il s'est déjà là je sais déjà assez
formidable alors j'ai juste changé le
plan de caméra d'accord pour qu'on
puisse bien voir tes regards c'est
quelqu'un de français c'est quelqu'un de
franc c'est super tu veux te voir ou pas
non non donc tu as un people en tête
c'est devenu assez spontanément
apparemment je vais te poser des
questions et à eux vont observer en même
temps que moi on va tous regardé je vais
essayer en même temps de désigner des
points sur ton visage qui se fait
analyser ça va bouger page
première question qui est une
affirmation mais je vérifie encore une
fois c'est quelqu'un de français oui on
est donc encore quelqu'un qui parle
français
on est d'accord ok vous avez vu quand il
lit on est d'accord il penche un petit
peu ici c'est sa manière de dire oui je
te poser des questions à partir de
maintenant tu vas me répondre mais que
dans sa tête dans taterka le roi sans
rien me dire
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est dans
le milieu artistique
quel qu'il soit le milieu large de la
télé vision jusqu'au cinéma en passant
par la scène oui sans répondre mais pas
la renommée
on leur fait
on a gagné une réponse c'est bon ça
d'accord merci ça nous en fait c'est un
petit pain akinator je suis en train
d'essayer
alors pour commencer c'est ça alors tu
sais quand je te poser des questions je
vais faire des affirmations et tu peux
les commenter dans ta tête très bien
comment tu juste hélas pas là juste là
que mon affirmation c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui est qui qui est souvent
sur scène en fait vous avez vu cette
petite déception juste là dans le regard
donc ça ça veut dire non mais mon
affirmation c'est que c'est quelqu'un
qu'on voit souvent au cinéma par contre
là vous avez vu ça s'est plus passé ici
au niveau des lèvres
c'est avec légèrement remonter donc pour
moi on est sur quelqu'un du cinéma on a
un petit week traîne c'est parfait je
dirais que c'est soit un homme soit une
femme
ok on a vu qu'il est revenu au repos au
niveau de la femme donc c'est un homme
ok alors si vous avez vu ma vidéo sur le
détecteur de mensonges on à la
créativité ici la mémoire ici il vient
d'aller en haut à droite donc ça veut
dire que tu étais en train de reprendre
une image visuelle de ta mémoire par
quel chemin je l'avais trouvée à bastien
tu sais quoi on va essayer de trouver la
première lettre de son prénom premières
lettres de son prénom qui pense tu va
regarder le capteur s'il te plaît et
quand tu entendras la lettre créera stop
dans ta tête mais dans ta tête tu me
rends c'est parti ça peut être a b c d e
f g h i j klm mène au pq est resté uv w
x y z
on a eu les yeux sur le p on a eu la
bouche sur le v donc ça doit être prouvé
en fait c'est plutôt cool de terrain la
chine au lit car cet homme est une
machine mais l'humain
ok prénom masculin qui commence par un v
je commence à avoir des idées
ok j'ai ressenti moi j'ai fini avec toi
je vais essayer de l'écrire ici est de
leur faire voir même sur leur dois ce
sera plus sympa je vais essayer de
l'écrire ici est de leur faire voir
confirme confirme bien que tu ne vois
pas à l'écran que l'écran est retourné
vers moi voilà fois par l'écran qu'on
pense pas que tu puisses faire ce que je
mets
j'écris très mal ne cherchait pas d'
embrouille sur ce que j'écris j'écris
juste très mal voilà sur quels acteurs
je m'arrête moi c'est presque un coup de
bluff encore une fois j'ai essayé de
vous emmener au départ sur le terrain
pour essayer de faire ma même temps que
moi mais j'ai un peu envie de vous
bluffez aussi donc je viens d'écrire
quelque chose ici est ce que tu peux me
dire quels acteurs étaient en train de
photographier derrière ton petit buisson
de paparazzi
c'était bien sûr vincent cassel vincent
cassel d'une mallié à la base c'était
vraiment super voilà ben bluffé comme
comme tous les autres forcément c'est
vrai cette appli ouais ouais ouais très
très très très très fort le vélv et
c'était moi les faits pourtant j'ai
essayé vraiment de ne rien laisser
paraître si relevé bon je suppose que je
suis lisible comme un livre ouvert mais
où tu le verras la beaucoup d'effet
après j'ai pris aussi en compte ton âge
des choses un peu particulière si vous
allez sur sa chaîne ce que je vous
recommande de vous mais la petite fille
juste là vous allez voir dans cette
vidéo de présentation anthony il
explique qu'il a 27 ans si on regarde
dans ses anciennes playlist de vidéo on
voit tout ce qui est l'univers du hard
rock ça donne aussi beaucoup d'indicés
en fait sur qui tu peux être question
sur sur ce que je pourrais aimer
exactement ce que je pourrais choisir
loi moi je pense que david hoberman pour
le coup exactement film c'est exactement
voilà c'était ma première
ma première pensée en fait d'autres
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
allez découvrir la chaîne d'anthony donc
c'est sûr le tuto photo moi j'y connais
rien en photo et j'apprends plein de
trucs grâce à sa chaîne et voilà merci
merci de ce que tu fais pas je compris
et puis merci de m'avoir accueilli
c'était une expérience unique je voulais
vraiment la vie courante
parce que on le voit en vidéo et au
final on on se dit toujours bon est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une complicité ce que
c'est
c'est vraiment bluffant que la merci
pour pour pour ce petit moment de
plaisir
chouette si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à nous en parler à laisser un petit
commentaire je lis nous parce qu'il
viendra lire les commentaires c'est
surtout sapin n'hésitez pas également à
nous laisser un petit ou sans l'air vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne si c'est pas fait vous pouvez
partager cette vidéo bref faites ce que
vous voulez rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mental
ciao